accompanied by close family members
Chili's president sebastián piñera took
part in the final farewell of his 104
year old uncle former Archbishop Bernard
we know Panetta health ministry protocol
stipulates that only five people can
attend the funeral of anyone suspected
of having died of covin 1920 in the case
of a person who has died of other causes
a former Archbishop had caught
coronavirus in May but according to his
doctors he recovered and died a short
time later of pneumonia the problem is
more than 30 people attended the funeral
when 20 is the maximum under the new
pandemic protocol the ceremony included
live music and photographers the
president demanded the sealed casket be
opened giving him one last chance to see
his uncle the deputy health minister
defended the president against
widespread charges of bad taste and
breaking his own rules a seated on the
CEO two personas there were only 18
family members at the funeral the casket
was sealed as stipulated I can assure
you everything was a hundred percent
according to protocol I don't think it's
right to use these situations of pain
especially during a pandemic but the
video clearly shows more people were
present in opposition congressman is
demanding an official probe by the
general prosecutor de Muerta not only
has the president broken the law he's
underscored the privileges that his
small caste enjoys while thousands of
ordinary Chileans are unable to give
their loved ones a dignified burial
during the pandemic the number of
confirmed kovat 19 cases in chile have
surpassed Italy Italy as well times
Chile's population but president piñera
is by no means the only Latin American
leader who's being accused of not quite
following the rules
in fact Brazil's president jailbot's
Inara has always made a point of not
following protocols such as social
distancing or wearing a face mask but
now he may have to do just that
following a new court ruling
a federal judge has ordered the
president to wear a mask in all public
spaces transportation and commercial
areas in the capital Brasilia like all
federal employees
failure to do so carries a $400 fine the
president has said in the past he'll
ignore court orders he regards as quote
absurd whether on purpose or not failure
to follow the few rules that can help
reduce the spread of this deadly virus
is sending a bad example in the region
that's now the epicenter of the pandemic
you see in human al Jazeera Santiago